so my name is Jay Beom Jo and the kernel
developer that wood frame research so
topic today shear is geometry data and
3d printing so simply say the print 3d
printing through Mathematica so we did
try is really printing area be poor but
at the time we only have the graphics
and she lovely say that just graphic or
on is not enough for 3d printing we also
need some information about like
geometry and geometric models something
like that and from like a bajan 10 we
add lots of new functionality about the
region is a mesh region so do
computational geometry area and those
functionality actually help or add to go
further in 3d printing area so just just
bleep the workflow for 3d printing the
first we need data so I'd say the model
to print so there are a couple ways in
Mathematica to get the model from
various area and after that we need to
verify the model we want to print is
decent so there are some also some
function we are developing for helping
those kind of stuffs at the end the
printing okay so first about the data
the first eg1 this constructor we have
copper ability in constructor in
Mathematica for exam from like
implication and then if you use on a
tangent discretized region then you got
the mesh region and this one you can
just send it to printer and print out
here is the new type of constructors
spin ski mesh so like this and also we
have one other one called minjur manager
mesh and also you can derive new mesh
region from some other message on using
some opera
Jones in mathematica easily and second
type of model you can get it promise and
get in mathematica is the curated the
data they are various created a time as
America and area is keep expanding so
one simple example is example data
geometry 3d sheer use GCC stove with
geometry 3d green apple data you can
expect from Mathematica and here is the
basic the graphics and then now we add
mesh region or boundary base region so
you can just get directory the mesh
radium from example data in another type
of curated data you can get its
polyhedron data chemical data slowly the
data and soft data also some like
anatomy data and there is much more and
even for example data we will expand the
collections so you will soon much much
more collection than now and also this
is just traditional way to get data from
a symmetrical so just use import so this
is your jam for stl file i scanned
downstairs and just import to miss
america and here's some new
functionality mess new the newer version
to flatten and reusing the smooth
shading I got something more realistic
the mesh now and for the import we also
improved a lot so like htlv also
supporting pier why obj obj we stopped
today before but now is much faster and
getting more data so there are some
improvement and then we this is all so
new functionality geometric 3d data in
actual this open the connection between
Mathematica to the outside service like
a same bers this is the region Provost
universe so think everyone know the
is what it is and then here's the one
example so you can just touch the cat in
the symbols and give you these to the
IDS the containing the cat and this each
model have various properties one of the
properties dominate so you can see the
thumbnail of each IDs so here is the
lizard so this is all correspond to
these IDs up here also you can just
extract mesh region then this is the
mesh region you can use in Mathematica
will print out and here's another jumper
so now I just want to get the newest
model in singing birds and show that
thumbnail and this is the result of
models so okay so when you get the data
now it comes to validate the model is ok
to print or not so for example like I
just hear the list hope things you need
to check people you send your model to
the service called shapeways so is from
their website documentation so you need
to make sure your mesh is watertight and
need to be taken some areas something
like that rah blah blah ok but with just
graphics it's very hard to check these
things but when you have a mesh region
it has some information inside already
like geometry and topology or cetera so
one of the things we are doing right now
we develop function easily check these
things so for example like a closeness
so this is a lady to hear your mesh need
to be water tight so it doesn't allow
any hole and into things so this is one
of the function we develop you evaluate
this with your note when episode
loading this notebook it did not work
because it's in the development corner
so I just want to show how this what
kind of function it is so it's just
simply check clothes news of this mesh
here definitely is not and then after
that you can extract the edges which
make this mesh region not closed and
after that eventually we're going to
have some deeper function to repairing
this defect on the mesh another example
of this function is like orientation
this look kind of decent but actually
this match is not oriented I mean
coherently oriented aware i mean is so
by checking this learning this function
over this mesh you say this force that
means there are some polygons which is
not oriented correctly and with this
function you can find out which polygons
actually have the problem is it so after
you got it you can reverse the
orientation to make it correct and then
using the new model to print out and
also other than these two function we
also plan to develop several other
functions like chatting nice hope mesh
so thing is what I mean is if you have
math for you jump like oh this one you
know this is paid very thin area this
one if you put this into 3d printer or
three principes they say no this is too
yes 0 so you need to take on this kind
of area and other than the the validate
I mean checking defect and repairing we
also have some southern operation you
can do over the mesh region to modify
your mesh for any implied extrusion and
union and call it corridas extrusion do
I mean the intersection and forums like
green legend legend Union legend
intersection yeah this function will
work will work on
yes 3d mesh regions and so there is
other thing you can do and so you have
mother and then you validate the model
it please ok to print out or not and
last thing you need to do is actually
printing so one traditional way to print
in Mathematica is exported to function
exporter mother and then using the
resulting file to print out and we want
to make the process a little bit easier
so we put some new function called print
of 3d so actually you just learn this
then you got some list this is a list of
sabe sprint or local printer the subsidy
by subsidy IDs function so we have like
you form 1 plus I met Tara lies this is
printing service make of all this local
printer and this to our also some auto
service so how we use it so for example
this is one example the printout 3d will
open up 3d printers programs for example
like I put the ledger board here and
then want to send this model to make
about so you can evaluate it this will
open up yes the MakerBot and put your
model in to make about software and now
you can print out using this one same
thing for tube it will open the QB pie
and send the model to their another
scenario is if you don't have any local
printer in your home then what you can
do is you can send this model to online
services to print out so one of the
example is Scott here is one of the
online service that sending new print if
you unload your model to their site so
in this case if you evaluate it
this will connect to their server I mean
there's obvious and open up the window
and the window the web browser and you
see the model I just send here and then
you can order it and you can change the
type of material you want and even you
can change the size and then just review
and check out paid and there is a new
printer
so yeah this one we will keep expanding
the supported service now we have like a
three services listed here but we will
keep talk with the external services and
make it some deal to provide nice
interface to Mathematica and also pull
the local printer we were also working
on with local printer vendors and 11 the
best scenario is the instead of open up
their software we want to really
dielectric went to printer like to the
printer does but currently is kind of
not easy to do it because there are
things we need to work with me more but
desta our kind of final goal to make EG
to all those process so this picture
here all the model here is made my
Mathematica or you know some from QA to
the data and I think most of you already
seen the downstair right so here's the
this model we I get this from the
anatomy data and print out miss america
and this one you know this is scanned
motor in the think yesterday and if
anyone recognizes your face then you can
have it we cannot find yet but this is
our team membership and this one we just
imported to miss america from i don't
even break that which side was it but
this one was Anna to me and this one
created by the employee I think your
employee region substrate that and this
one actually we send this data to
chevrolet and this is what i got from
them so
this is kind of very popular area right
now so we will keep walking on and we
will keep improved that's our plan and
actually this is end of talk